so there are three ways that you might
be able to get yourself health insurance
the first way is that you just get it
directly and that would be an individual
plan you pray you pay the premium you
get the insurance the second way is many
employers will provide insurance they
will pay all of the premium or large
chunk of the premium in certain cases
they might even pay a large chunk or the
full premium for family members and then
the Third Way is the government you have
programs like Medicare for primarily
senior citizens some other cases where
other folks might qualify as well you
have Medicaid for low-income folks you
have also government programs for say
veterans
now as I just alluded to probably the
biggest difference is who actually makes
the payment the government programs it's
the government who's making the premium
payment in the employer case it's the
employer and they're doing that with
pre-tax money which matters they're
giving this to you as a benefit and you
do not pay taxes on the money that they
are paying for your insurance well with
an individual plan you pay that out of
pocket you pay that for you pay that
yourself now if you meet certain income
guidelines and if you pay enough of a
premium above a certain percentage of
your income some of that might be tax
deductible but it is not fully tax
deductible the same way that when your
employer pays for it you don't have to
pay any taxes on that on that premium
that they're providing you at all now on
the individual side because you are
essentially deciding what type of
insurance you want it would give you the
maximum choice now in certain cases that
choice is limited because when you're
getting an individual plan they're
deciding what the premium is or whether
to even insure you based on your
situation whether you have pre-existing
conditions your risk factor
Etc while with a government or with an
employer plan they're not looking at
your individual circumstances with an
employer the insurance company will say
okay what's the average risk of all the
employees and if you're a higher risk
employee the employer is going to pay
the same premium for you as they're
paying for everyone else and so you get
that same coverage one potential
negative of an employer plan is that it
might be a little bit more limited in
terms of the coverage options but that's
not always the case
finally government you are going to have
probably more limits on what type of
Health Care you might get but once again
they are fully paying the premium there
last but not least we could talk about
deductibles generally speaking the
government plans are going to have the
lowest deductibles in some cases they
will have no deductibles in the case of
an employer sponsored plan or an
individual plan it really depends on
which plan you actually get so for a lot
of folks if you're not retired if you're
not
um low-income employer sponsored plans
are probably where you want to go but if
your employer doesn't offer those plans
or you're self-employed and you get that
insurance yourself then of course
individual plans is what you need to do